good evening and welcome this evening
I'm honored to be here speaking on
behalf of our Academy president John
Bailey who's on a plane on his way to
London to greet new Academy members
tonight we gather not only to celebrate
another milestone in a contest that
first introduced the world to names like
Robert Zemeckis Cary Fukunaga Trey
Parker and Spike Lee but to March and a
movement which through the example of
recent winners like Patricia Reagan and
Patricia Cardoso is helping yeah
absolutely it's helping to break
Hollywood's glass ceiling but above all
we are here to introduce the world
to those who will write the next chapter
in the story that's called film that's
you guys
this year as we have since 1972 we honor
an amazing group of filmmakers and we
can only do it thanks to the
record-breaking nearly 700 Academy
members who served as judges choosing
from fifteen hundred and eighty-two
entries from four hundred schools
yeah after tonight the numbers alone
will tell a story that defies even the
most optimistic predictions of those who
filled the room at the first awards show
forty-five years five hundred and three
winners so to all those judges from all
those years we say thank you
and to all of tonight's winners an
entrance in this year's competition
congratulations
congratulations but remember the Student
Academy Awards is not an inheritance
it's an invitation an invitation to keep
dreaming and discovering learning and
leading and to be that generation that
takes movie magic to new heights of
daring and determination the light of
film doesn't shine automatically we're
counting on all of you to keep it
shining now it's my pleasure to
introduce a pasta student Academy Award
winner and now the chairman of the
Student Academy Awards a writer and
director who has traveled the globe from
India to North Korea to tell stories
that the world needs to see please
welcome Greg healthy
[Music]